the white house is finally opening up
they are finally talking about it the
most significant widespread phenomenon
to hit the country all year
the white house
is finally addressing the social
contagion
of let's go brandon
one last question if i can't quickly
across this country we've seen this new
phenomenon lately chanted at sporting
events and on science the phrase is
let's go brandon the sort of code for a
profane slogan attacking president biden
what does the president make of that
i don't think he spends much time
focused on it or thinking about it he
doesn't he doesn't spend much time
thinking about that maybe he should
spend a little time thinking about it
maybe if he spent a little more time
thinking about why tens of thousands of
people at every game and concert in the
country have for weeks been telling
brandon to go go himself maybe then his
approval numbers wouldn't be at historic
lows
and setting the stage for a potentially
historic drubbing in the midterm
elections i'm michael knowles this is
the micro mall show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment on friday is from real life
outdoors who says you know what the best
part of this whole written house trial
is nothing absolutely nothing remember
the day when you realized that you live
in a kafka novel that's true what's the
silver lining here i get look
something has to be the best part even
if it's just terrible right what what's
the what's the best part of of you know
getting a flat tire i don't know at
least it's not raining or something and
here at least it looks like rittenhouse
might get off the hook but i i agree the
fact that this trial can happen in the
first place is an indictment of the
country and
it really overshadows whatever that
silver lining is going to be we got to
think of the good old days those happy
memories when you want to preserve them
into the future i'd strongly recommend
you check out legacy box legacy box is
the best way to preserve your past this
makes a great christmas gift
in particular because it'll protect a
lot of wonderful past christmas memories
and all sorts of memories and your your
videos and your photos and all those
physical media that are decaying right
now and at risk of fire or flood or just
getting lost well what legacy box does
is you send in all those physical media
and they digitize your moments onto a
thumb drive the dvd
or the cloud it's like magic
now if you're like most people there's
that one box you'd run back into your
house to grab because it's got all your
memories and it's filled with videotapes
and film reels and photos these
sentimental meaningful irreplaceable
moments no amount of money can replace
them well send them into legacy box each
item is digitized by hand that keep you
informed they're trusted by one million
people it's easy and safe and you get
the physical media back afterward i love
it i thought i lost every photo of my
mother and i did find them sending them
right in to legacy box legacy box is
giving our listeners early access to
their black friday sale go to
legacybox.com knowles to unlock an
exclusive discount for black friday
legacybox.com knowles for the best deal
of the year legacybox.com
knowles
the numbers for the democrats
are devastating
okay
and we always say well maybe i don't
believe the polls maybe the polls are
slanted right the polls are slanted for
democrats so the fact that the numbers
are this bad for democrats means they're
even actually worse for democrats in
reality than are reflected in the
surveys washington post abc poll if the
midterm elections were held today the
gop would be in an historically strong
position
right now
this poll this was released on sunday
found that if the midterms were held
today registered voters would vote for
republicans for congress over democrats
by a point margin
51 percent to 41 percent
wapo calls this and quote historically
strong result for republicans
biden's approval rating so this is just
focused on
the president
it's 12 points underwater only 41
percent of registered voters approve of
the job he has done as president
53 percent disapprove of the job he has
done
brutal news for democrats
but don't get too excited
i promise you the gop will find some way
to squander this okay
the republican party
will find some way
to squander this huge advantage they
have right now they're going to make it
about socialism or some other nonsense
they're gonna they're gonna take all of
this historic momentum and support and
the grassroots movement on the ground to
protect kids in schools and to get the
crt and the transgender theories out of
schools they're gonna find a way to
squander it and make this about
corporate tax cuts
okay now are they gonna are they going
to so
squander their advantage that they
actually lose the election probably not
but they will figure out some way to
screw this up this is just what they do
because they believe
that it is much better
to avoid all of the social issues that
actually help them win elections they
think it's too dangerous and if we talk
about critical race theory that might
turn off some suburban people and you
know and and it might not seem really
fancy and make us seem like you know
sophisticates at the cocktail parties
and we better not talk about any you
know abortion that's so divisive isn't
it and we better not talk about
family and marriage that that's that's
yucky let's just talk about cutting
taxes for billionaires who hate our guts
that's a good idea right the thing you
got to remember
and the thing i hope the republican
party remembers as it looks toward the
midterms
is that sometimes the apparently safest
issue
is not the safest issue the safest
tactic very often is not the safest
tactic
talking about tax cuts or running a
campaign like romney 2012 that might
seem like the safest campaign because
you're not making any sudden movements
you're not going out on a limb you're
not risking anything but it's it's only
going to safely put you into second
place think about it when you're driving
sometimes when you're driving and i
don't want to sound sexist about it but
this might be a little bit of a
difference between male drivers and
female drivers
right just to talk about the difference
between men and women
sometimes male drivers will be more
aggressive
and sometimes female drivers such as my
wife will not like this very much and
she'll say don't don't hit the
accelerator so much go a little slower
but sometimes when you're driving
to be a little more aggressive is
actually the safer option if it's you on
a mac truck and the mac truck is is
about to enter onto the highway and
you're driving you want to get a little
bit ahead of it it's actually safer for
you to accelerate a little bit get ahead
of that truck so that it's not going to
come and smack you in the side and the
gop needs to learn that lesson sometimes
you've got to accelerate on an issue
like education critical race theory
transgender theory
i'll use another analogy i'll mix my
metaphors when you're playing blackjack
you are guaranteed to lose the house is
guaranteed to win you are guaranteed to
lose unless
you play
the the good hands you get in the right
way you split when you're supposed to
split you double down when you're
supposed to double down if you do that
you're almost even odds the house still
has an advantage the democrats still
have an advantage but if we press our
advantage if we press the few advantages
that we get
we actually have a chance of winning
have i given enough metaphors on this
gop don't squish good grief speaking of
goofy swamp republicans liz cheney liz
jenny she's at it again she's up to her
usual tricks
ted cruz
our pal ted cruz made a joke about liz
cheney
cnn asked implausibly if liz cheney has
a lane for the 2024
presidential race
and
cruz made a joke and said yes she has a
lane in the in the democrat primary so
liz cheney responds and says this
i know you're posturing for the
secessionist vote ted but my party the
republican party saved the union
you swore an oath to the constitution
act like it my party i'm the republican
you're a fake republican ted cruz you're
a fake republican donald trump you're a
fake republican all the people who
actually still vote republican and
support the people the republican party
supports but me liz cheney frequent
appearance guest on on cnn and abc and
nbc and in the washington post and i'm
the real
republican i who do nancy pelosi's
bidding i'm the real republican it's not
true
it's not true
i know that liz cheney is still
registered with the republican party
i know that historically she's cast at
least a lot of votes for republicans
most votes for not you know she's not
the most right-wing person but most
votes sure she's voted with the
republicans but practically speaking
liz cheney is a democrat
this is when i talk about the court
jester conservatives
people like her like adam kinzinger like
the never trumpers i think there are
three of them left in the world
they are practically democrats they
might vote republican
99 of the time
and they can still be these court
jesters they can still practically be
democrats
because at the crucial moments
on the crucial votes at the decisive
places
they side with the democrats
yeah liz cheney she'll vote for all the
tax cuts in the world
but when it comes to the january 6th
commission that seeks to delegitimize
half of this country she's going to side
with the democrats when it comes to the
presidential contest the republican
versus the democrat she's going to side
with the democrat
she and has in recent years
okay and so there's nothing look
there's nothing really unusual about
someone leaving a political party people
have done that throughout history okay i
don't i don't begrudge liz cheney
leaving her political party
or spending all of her time criticizing
the republican party that she still
stubbornly won't leave
but it is ridiculous to pretend
that she is now still representing the
republican party it's not true
the only people who even pretend to
support her at this point are democrats
and they're going to throw her out the
second she's no longer useful to them
no republicans support liz cheney liz
cheney doesn't support republicans or
republican
or the republican party so she's gone
please save me your sanctimony liz
you've got to get
aggressive okay and you've got to be
able to push forward on the issues that
are going to help republicans right now
you're seeing this happen
in
florida you're seeing this happen
around the country but but especially in
florida okay
do not be like liz cheney be like ted
cruz be like ron desantis ron desantis
right now
through government force through public
relations through the backbone that he's
got
has managed to win a major fight with
the florida school district over
mask
mandates all right you you've got to
keep your kids safe you've got to keep
your whole family safe in your house and
that's why i would recommend you check
out
ring the holiday season is upon us and
you know what that means your in-laws
are going to show up wouldn't you like
to know
when that will occur well you can with
ring you know i now listen i'm not
saying you're not going to open the door
okay i'm just saying
that when whether you're in your home or
at the office or on a beach you can know
when your mother-in-law shows up and you
can make your own decision okay the ring
video doorbell is all about empowering
you or it could be the delivery guy or
whoever whoever it is all right you can
get a lot of packages well ring makes
the powerful ring alarm so it's not just
the video doorbell helps you keep an eye
on every inch of your house inside
and out it's so easy to install you can
do it yourself
for the cost of a year of protection
with rig alarm that's that's basically
just one month of protection with those
other expensive companies head on over
right now to ring.com
knowles deck the halls walls doors and
windows with the best deals of the year
ring.com
knowles canon wlas to get a great deal
on your ring alarm security kit today a
florida school district has finally
finally dropped its mask mandate for
students
this is after the school district
suspended an eight-year-old girl
38 times
38 times for not wearing the mandate now
you'll remember
that
ron desantis governor of florida said
that schools do not have the right to
issue blanket mask mandates without
exceptions
the school district said forget about
governor desantis we're going to do it
anyway
the little girl said and i assumed the
girl's family
said no we're going to follow what the
governor said
we're not going to do it
and second grader fiona lachelles
was suspended 38 times
and now
the mask
order is gone this is following a ruling
from division of administrative hearings
judge
newman who declared that
the department of health's emergency
rule the desantis rule is valid here is
the little girl appearing side by side
with governor desantis
i'm not wearing a mask because you touch
it and you have germs on your hand and
then you put it on your face and breathe
in all the germs that's right so so
governor i remember in the summer you
signed an executive order
that mask
mask wearing was optional in the public
schools but then the palm beach county
schools said you know what you got to
wear a mask so you know
kids like fiona are caught in the middle
so we've had a lot of litigation since
then fortunately we're winning all these
cases
steve and i'm going to have a
legislative session come in a special
session primarily to deal
with protecting people's jobs against
covet vacs requirements uh but we're
also going to address this issue of our
parents bill of rights and making sure
that we have strong teeth in it so that
if you have a situation where fiona is
forced to do this and that's not
something her mother wants her to do
then the parent ultimately makes a
decision so we are going to strengthen
that and we're going to make sure that
folks are able to go to school in the
best possible way for them and for their
learning experience
ron desantis is such a talented
politician it is ridiculous he just
one he knows how to keep himself in the
national conversation
just about every single day two he knows
to appear on screen with this very
sympathetic young girl this
eight-year-old girl who's being attacked
by her school district for just trying
to breathe the fresh air
and three and this is the most important
one this is the lesson we need to take
the guy is persistent
okay
most
republicans go squishy
right most republicans go squishy
basically from the beginning and they
negotiate against themselves and they
don't fight that hard and they let the
democrats run run all over them
some republicans will push hard for a
little bit and they'll get an executive
order through
and they'll get maybe they'll get some
ruling through and it'll just be one
thing and then it's done
but then what happens because the
democrats are very persistent all those
republican victories just get chipped
and chipped and chipped away at
what desantis is doing he issued his his
mask mandate saying or his anti-mask
mandate mandate saying that the schools
don't have the right to implement these
kind of policies but then he kept
fighting them every single time a school
would violate
his
his rule
he would take them to task in the court
of public opinion in the court of law he
would go on tv with an eight-year-old
girl
and because of that because he's
matching the democrat persistence with
his own
he wins it's a major victory
and i strongly suspect
other republican politicians are going
to follow him
even even the cautious ones
because i think they're learning the
lesson
that
sometimes being cautious is not the most
cautious policy sometimes playing it's
safe is not the safest way you can play
it sometimes actually getting a little
aggressive
is a safer way
to play it
great politics
now speaking of democrats abusing kids
they're doing it they're doing it the
libs like we said they would like we all
predicted the libs
are defending
pedos
they are and you always hear about the
conspiracy theories and the democrats
and the pedophiles well sometimes it's
not a conspiracy theory sometimes it's a
conspiracy theorem you know sometimes
it's a conspiracy fact and the democrats
i shouldn't say the debt i should say
the libs more broadly are defending
pedos a non-binary
also known as very confused professor of
sociology and criminal justice at old
dominion university someone named alan
walker
has now gone viral thanks to our friends
at libs of tick tock
uh
defending
pedophiles and pedophilia and
attractions toward kids which he says
we need to be far more sensitive about
we need to stop using this loaded term
pedophile and start calling these people
maps
i use the term minor attracted person or
map in the title and throughout the book
for multiple reasons
first of all because i think it's
important to use terminology for groups
that members of that group want others
to use for them
and math advocacy groups like before you
act
have advocated for use of the term map
they've advocated for it primarily
because it's less stigmatizing than
other terms like pedophile
a lot of people when they hear the term
pedophile they automatically assume that
it means a sex offender and that isn't
true and it leads to a lot of
misconceptions about attractions toward
minors
i've definitely heard the idea that you
brought up though that the use of the
term minor attracted person suggests
that it's okay to be attracted to
children
but using a term that communicates who
someone is attracted to
doesn't indicate anything about the
morality of that attraction it doesn't
end indicate anything about the morality
it's just really stigmatizing you know
and we shouldn't have any stigmas around
anything at all
according to our modern liberal society
including pedophilia
there should be no stigmas
he what can what can he do there's
nothing immoral
and you know let's follow this guy's
logic illogic to its logical conclusion
or it's illogical conclusion
why is it immoral
why is why is an attraction
toward a
young a minor why is it immoral if
you're not sexually abusing the minor
why is it let's say you're just looking
at um
you're looking at a bunch of kitty porn
why is that immoral okay well you could
say it's immoral because obviously
children were abused in the production
of that pornography okay what about if
it's computer generated
let's say it's um
[Music]
a cartoon let's say that it's and now
you know technology is so advanced let's
say it looks real but it's not actually
real no children were harmed in the
production of this creepy stuff
i we all suspect that would be immoral
we all know deep down that that would be
immoral to do that to look at that kind
of material to indulge those kinds of
thoughts and attractions
but why
why in our modern world we're told that
the only thing that matters is consent
and so okay you're going to tell me that
kids can't give consent first of all the
libs don't even believe that themselves
ki libs not only believe that the kids
can consent to sexual acts they believe
they can consent to sexual mutilation
and surgery they believe a five-year-old
can mutilate his own body so that if
he's a boy he can look more like a girl
or vice versa he can know his true
gender even even if
even if his true gender has nothing to
do with reality but okay let's say that
now you're back to kids can't give
consent well why is it wrong for an
adult creepy man like that person
or someone like him
to look at
material that depicts children in sexual
acts even if it doesn't use real
children
why is it wrong because consent isn't
the only thing
you need consent
but there's more there are some things
that are objectively wrong
and objectively disordered
not just as some quirk of psychology but
morally as well
and some desires are wrong
and if those desires are unwilled if
those desires are involuntary we all
have certain involuntary desires whether
it's for some creepy stuff like this guy
or whether it's for too many cupcakes
some of our desires are going to be
disordered and so if we don't will them
it's not not a sin exactly but we
certainly shouldn't indulge it would be
a sin to indulge those desires or those
fantasies or those thoughts that would
be wrong but because we don't have any
of that moral language anymore
because we're not allowed to talk about
sin and grace and vice and virtue all we
ever talk about is
this kind of
basic shallow consent or the kind of
materialistic stuff about quirks of
psychology or mental health because we
can't actually talk about morality
anymore
now you've got the libs defending
pedophiles because they were born that
way they say
and because we're told that our desires
never change and we can't shape our
desires you're just you're born that way
and you've always got to indulge your
desire and if it feels good do it and
you should never repress anything well
okay if that's true i think that's crazy
but that is the idea of the sexual
revolution that's been building for 70
years now so if that's true
then
we should destigmatize the pedophiles
right and if we shouldn't destigmatize
the pedophiles
as i think we could probably all agree
we shouldn't
then maybe we need to rethink all the
other
premises of the sexual revolution too
looking around our society today
i think we need to rethink a lot of
things
just look at the gas prices look just
look at at the gas pump when you go fill
up your car
probably need to rethink that one way
you can rethink that in a really
practical way go check out get upside
get upside that is both a command and
the name of the app it's get upside
right now my listeners are making up to
25 cents for every gallon of gas every
time they fill up just download the free
get upside app in the app store or
google play right now use promo code
knowles canon wles get a bonus 25 cents
per gallon on your first fill up that is
up to 50 cents cash back do not pay full
price at the pump anymore get cash back
using get upside use promo code knowles
cannonwles to get 50 cents per gallon
cash back on your first tank people who
drive a lot right now are making as much
as two to three hundred bucks in cash
per
month and it gets added right to your
account goes to your bank account or
paypal or an e-gift card for amazon or
other brands super simple download the
free get upside app use promo code
knowlescannonwles
make it a little bit easier to deal with
these rising gas prices with promo code
nulls you can get up to 50 cents per
gallon cashback on your first tank that
is code knowles also subscribe and start
listening to morning wire on apple
spotify or wherever you listen to
podcasts leave a five star review if you
like what you hear
we'll be right back with a lot more
i've heard a criticism from the left
that
accusations of pedophilia
from the right are like accusations of
racism from the left
and and all the farthest fringe theories
on the right
they very often come down to pedophilia
and the furthest fringe theories on the
left which are now completely mainstream
they often come down to race and
everybody's a racist okay that
fair enough i mean
the only thing i'll say is it's not just
fringe lunatic professors on the left
who are
covering up and encouraging the sexual
abuse of kids it's the mainstream left
too this headline from the new york
times astounded even me and my
expectations for the gray lady are
pretty low they're about as low as they
can get here's the headline
how a school district got caught in
virginia's political maelstrom
sub-headline
loudoun county tried to address racism
and promote diversity within its schools
then it found itself on fox news
first of all that's not true the
the media institution that took down
loudoun county and
affected the election was not was not
that that cable news network it was the
daily wire and it was our story that was
not about
addressing racism and promoting
diversity and tolerance and inclusion it
was a story about a rape in a
transgender bathroom that's what it was
about
it was a story about a guy wearing a
skirt raping a ninth grade girl in a
bathroom and and it wasn't even just
about that
terrible crimes happen it was about the
cover-up that the school then engaged in
that's what it was about
evangelical christians objected to a
proposal to give transgender students
access to the restrooms of their choice
complaints that were magnified when a
male student wearing a skirt was
arrested in an assault in a girl's
bathroom he was a male student wearing a
skirt was arrested and oh you mean
a dude raped a girl
and
people didn't bat an eyelash that he was
in there because boys are now allowed in
the girls room
because of the transgender bathroom
policies this is
the
extreme version of republicans pounds do
you know republicans pounce you know
this phenomenon
this is when democrats get caught in a
scandal
or a crime
and the headline is not democrats commit
crime the headline is republicans pounce
on democrats committing the crime so
that all of the focus is on the
republicans taking what they suggest to
be an illegitimate
advantage they're exploiting
democrats committing this crime i'm not
saying that the new york times
is eager for kids to be abused or
anything like that i'm saying they don't
care about kids being abused and they
are much happier with kids being abused
if that is the price of them
pushing through their agenda than they
would be in sacrificing their agenda to
protecting kids the headline says it all
so
so you want to talk about exploitation
when it's uh you know just that the
usual democrat gets caught in some usual
scandal and then republicans pounce
that's one thing
but this to to turn the real story the
work that the new york times should have
been doing themselves
on loudoun county
to then attack other media organizations
and they don't even get the name of the
organization right it's the daily wire
they're coming after
if
for them to do that is is a new low
speaking into the mainstream media going
into overdrive to reclaim the narrative
don lemon
don lemon is very very upset about the
biggest story i can't this is the
longest we haven't talked about it in
any show in probably two weeks
the written house story you know where
all of the evidence is on the side of
kyle rittenhouse that young man in
kenosha wisconsin who shot the antifa
people who were trying to murder him
all of the evidence is on his side none
of the evidence is on the prosecution
side it seems like the case is falling
apart before our very eyes and don lemon
he's really upset about that he wants to
know what would happen
if kyle rittenhouse were a black kid
just want to leave people with a picture
here are you going imagine
if kyle rittenhouse was an 18 or 17 year
old black kid well that's a different
issue with a gun and talk about that
right how would people feel how would
the judge treat him how would pundits
think about this this case uh what about
the people on the right who are making
kyle rittenhouse out to be a choir boy
because he went across state lines
inserted himself into a situation where
he that he had nothing to do with was
carrying a gun that he wasn't supposed
to carry because it was he was too young
it was illegal for him to carry that gun
and he wanted to he wanted to do it
because he was cool
uh the black kid did that killed two
people and injured another person how
would america feel about that
first of all the hypothetical what would
happen if a young black man let's say a
young black man in these very riots that
that kyle rittenhouse went to what would
happen if he had a gun or some weapon
and were committing violence how what
would happen then we know what would
happen then they'd get off the hook
that's what would happen that's what's
been happening
for
most of the people that were involved in
the blm riots last year
you saw it especially in in the bronx
and in manhattan
people pleading down having much more
serious charges now just be minor
trespassing or some some lower charge
what would happen if a young black man
were looting or robbing or mugging
people or killing people during the blm
riots what would happen nothing would
happen
they'd face very
lenient
prosecution and that and they would get
cover from the media who were saying
they were involved in anti-racist
protests which is not what happened but
let's let's take this further
let's not just
compare things that
share some similarities let's say
that kyle rittenhouse himself were a
black guy
so not a young black man showing up to
the blm side and protesting for blm not
a young man showing up and joining
antifa but a young black man
showing up to his place of business with
an ar-15 he's clearly more conservative
he's there a young black man who who
shoots some antifa people who are trying
to attack him
how would how would the right react
the wright would love that guy
the right would defend that guy every
bit as much as they are kyle rittenhouse
and we all know it
one because the evidence would be on his
side
but two
because he the guy would be on our side
right right
of course
conservatives
love
black people who support conservatives
don't i thought the left was just
attacking us for that that we like
thomas soul too much or we like candace
owens too much or we like are we like
this woman who won in in virginia the
lieutenant governor of virginia win some
sears remember there were all these
headlines white supremacists always
loved black conservatives yeah so what
would happen if the
if the
kyle rittenhouse case if that were a
young black guy well all those
conservatives who the left says are
white supremacist evil
they would by their own logic they would
support him right
right now it just so happens all the
evidence would be on his side too and it
just so happens that the right wingers
are not white supremacist evil whatever
nonsense
but i just think even on the point don
lemon's making he's not right
because
the thing that matters here is substance
as well as form okay for the left it's
it's just about form i guess
it's just about how someone looks the
kind of superficial similar what about
the substance what are these guys
fighting for it's a big difference if a
guy shows up to a blm rally
or an antifa rally with a gun
and starts aggressing on people
i'm going to have a very different view
of him than if someone shows up to that
same rally on the side of the business
owners on the side of the
civilians on the side of the
conservatives and is not aggressing but
actually just defending himself i guess
they both in both cases they both look
like a guy with a gun
but what they are they're doing is very
very
different
it's just so cheap you know the libs are
getting desperate because they're now
they're just making it all about race
by the way kyle written the only people
kyle written has shot are white guys
if he had shot a black guy that there
would be the the msm would would turn
the
the demagoguery up to 11. but because he
only shot white guys they can't really
do that they're trying to but so they're
still trying to play the race card and
it's just it's not working as well
here's another headline from cnn
uh
kyle what what kyle rittenhouse's tears
reveal about white america they say kyle
rittenhouse the 18 year old on trial in
kenosha wisconsin for shooting three
people and killing two of them
represents the epitome of white
privilege in america run amok
white privilege this guy was
having people tell him they were going
to murder him
chase him down and point guns at his
head
and then only then did he shoot them in
self-defense
and he's still on trial
that's white privilege
in a sane society
this would never have gone to trial
in a really sane society
when you've got
three criminals attacking a 17 year old
boy
criminals with a long rap sheet
serial child rapists that sort of thing
it wouldn't it's not that we would put
kyle rittenhouse on trial we'd give him
an award
we'd put a ribbon around his neck
but he has white privilege
and so maybe he'll get through this
trial by the skin of his teeth cbs
morning tweeted out
kyle written has quote murdered two men
they said they reported this as fact of
course the trial is there to determine
whether or not he murdered two men and
all the evidence says he didn't murder
them
but but cbs news is network news just
reports it is fact that he's guilty
so i guess the trial is superfluous
now this is not really working
this is not really i made this point on
backstage the other night this is not
really working
because every single detail here
is in kyle rittenhouse's favor
the kid didn't take a bad shot
every single second of this interaction
which was captured on drones and
actually
there was
quite a bit of evidence that we actually
hadn't even been told about in the
public before the media completely
convicted him in the court of public
opinion
everything was in his favor here
and still it's close if he had done
anything wrong if he'd fired one bad
shot if he had been a little bit
reckless if he had
this would be a completely different
story
so real the race card's really not
working they're so desperate now they're
trying to accuse the judge of being a
racist because he made a joke about the
supply chain
uh let's hope for one o'clock i don't
know the uh hope the asian food isn't
coming it's on isn't on one of those
boats in long long beach harbor
um but let's uh
aim for one o'clock
so
they we're having some asian food for
lunch that day at the trial and the
judge made a
nerdy dad joke about the supply chain he
says oh well you know i i hope the asian
food is not uh on the container ships
with all those other asian products in
the long beach harbor because then we
won't get it
right it's not
not exactly don rickles okay but
he's no bob hope but it's a perfectly
fine anodyne little joke and they're
saying it's racist
it's racist why what why is it racist
because you
mention
a people
did you mention that asian goods come
from asia you make a little joke it's it
whatever it is any time a white guy ever
says anything about race
that we and if we don't like that guy
then whatever he said is racist
not persuading
anybody
and frankly what i mean this gets back
to the election point here
i think this stuff redounds to the
benefit of republicans and conservatives
if we can press that advantage
if we if we just run on this if we run
on the kyle rittenhouse trial
and the character assassination of
people
with the r word with the racist word who
who do not deserve that word at all and
we run on critical race theory in
schools and we run on
little
boys and girls being told that they're
evil because of the color of their skin
and we run on
little boys and girls being told that
they're not really the sex that they are
and we run on little boys and girls
being told to mask up constantly and not
see any smiling faces if we run on this
kind of cultural stuff we're gonna win
okay
but the republican party is just too
nervous they're so
cowardly they don't ever want to be
called
racist it's the worst thing it can be
called in america today they don't want
to be called that even if it's
disingenuous even if it's not true
even if it's as frivolous as someone
accusing this judge of racism for making
a joke about asian food
and it's not even actually a joke about
asian food it's a joke about the supply
chain
they they want to play it safe and if
they play it safe they're going to
safely lose and if they get a little
more aggressive they're going to have a
far better chance
of winning
speaking of race is a political issue
the north dakota governor right now just
banned critical race theory from schools
and you're seeing a lot more of these
bans cropping up so the devil's always
in the details what what is actually
being banned here because what the left
is going to say is there's no such thing
as critical race theory what is critical
race theory they retreat into nominalism
they say oh who even knows what that
term means
meanwhile they know what that term means
they've been pushing critical race
theory for decades and at the out of the
other side of their mouth they'll say
critical race theory is great we need to
push it
and then from the other side they'll say
no it's not even being taught in schools
and it's not really anything and it
doesn't really exist so here's the text
of it
of the rule a school district or public
school may not include instruction
relating to critical race theory in any
portion of the school's
required curriculum or any other
curriculum offered by the district or
the school for purposes of this section
critical race theory means the theory
that racism is not merely the product of
learned individual bias or prejudice but
that racism is systematically embedded
in american society and the american
legal system to facilitate
racial inequality that's a pretty good
definition
you know i've got a book somewhere here
around my desk i've got
basically the definitive book of essays
and
uh documents
outlining
critical race theory
from kimberly crenshaw onward but that's
pretty good that's a pretty good
description of it and that should not be
taught in schools
and
this is something republicans and
conservatives should embrace
they don't want to because they're all
about the free marketplace of ideas and
liberty and you know which isn't really
liberty but kind of licentiousness
masquerading as liberty and the idea
that we should never ban any any phrase
or word or anything because we've we've
gone way too far in the other direction
on free speech and we
actually have kind of taken free speech
beyond its historical boundaries
and
philosophical coherence and now we say
you should be able to say anything you
want but you shouldn't be able to say
anything you want especially not in
high schools in middle schools and
elementary schools there have to be
limits here
and yeah now now what this needs is
teeth though
take the desantis lesson
it's not enough to pass the the law it's
not enough
to say okay now we've banned critical
race theory no some school is going to
violate that probably most schools are
going to violate that and what then
you got to fire the teachers or the
administrators or both
and you've got to go through the long
legal process and you've got to take it
to court and you've got to get the win
desantis
bans the mask mandates the blanket mask
mandates and then the school suspends
this girl and then she keeps keeps it up
and she keeps it up she gets suspended
38 times and desantis goes on national
television with her and he fights them
in court and then finally finally the
law's got some teeth that's what's going
to have to happen here in north dakota
you can't take that that easy little win
you've got to push it so that it
actually can be
effective
on another big campaign issue it's not
it's not just the
cultural stuff right it's not just crt
and the gender theory that is going to
help us biden is losing on every single
issue right now notably inflation
because people are seeing it when they
buy their groceries when they
go to the gas pump
i don't know that much about grocery
shopping i do it very infrequently in my
house but i went to pick up some things
at the grocery store yesterday and even
i noticed it prices are going way up on
everything plus store shelves are
emptying out
this is a big campaign issue first the
democrats denied it
then
they downplayed it
now they're saying actually it's like
it's either not a not a big deal or it's
actually sort of a good thing stephanie
rule from msnbc
steph it's great to see you as you say
inflation's over six percent numbers we
haven't seen in more than 30 years so
how much higher can these prices go and
when do you see them coming down well
listen willie nobody knows exactly when
they're going down but you have to put
all this in perspective this inflation
is not in isolation and the government
predicted it was going to be a
challenging recovery recovery all tied
to covid so it's why you see things like
that expanded child tax credit you've
got the families of over 60 million kids
on average getting 430 dollars a month
for people on fixed incomes older people
on social security they're getting those
fixed payments adjusted next year of 5.9
percent for inflation and the dirty
little secret here willie while nobody
likes to pay more on average we have the
money to do so household savings hit a
record high over the pandemic we didn't
really have anywhere to go out and spend
this is actually you know look you look
at all this inflation and actually maybe
it's just because you guys got so much
money huh
you guys you're actually doing great
you're doing great did you know that
and look the people who are on the
government dole and rely on not not just
on the dole as though they're welfare
cases but people who've paid into the
system who are now on fixed incomes from
the state the state's going to give you
a little bit more money
you know they're going to print they're
going to print up a lot more money you
know the thing that got us into this
mess in the first place they're going to
do more of that so it's fine
it's fine and we've got we're all really
rich and it's really not a big deal
i don't think that's a winning campaign
line for democrats
i
i don't i don't think hey you're
complaining about the gas prices and the
and your thanksgiving dinner costs and
it will well shut up you're fine you're
rich
are you i don't know i don't think
people are prepared
for record high inflation
it doesn't matter how much whether
you've got a really
modest resources or whether you're quite
wealthy i mean you you tend to scale
your lifestyle to those things and so
when prices go up 10 20
in some cases they're doubling seven
dollar gas in california that's going to
have an effect on you
now speaking of campaigns i got to get
to this story before we go i'll at least
touch on it
there's a rumor
that new york governor andrew
cuomo former new york governor andrew
cuomo disgraced new york governor andrew
cuomo
might run for attorney general of new
york so he's not going to run for
governor there's already a governor
there and multiple other people are
running for governor including the
current attorney general so andrew cuomo
who already was the attorney general
might run for that post again according
to reports
now is this true is this real it sounds
like he's floating the idea of it
all i will say on this point people are
laughing oh my gosh this disgraced
governor he's now under sexual
investigation he there's no way he could
don't count this guy out
don't count him out
he's persistent the cuomo's have
dominated new york politics for the
better part of 40 years
don't count him at persistence
is the key here
and
the democrats know persistence and
they've used it very effectively and the
republicans who are winning right now
are persistent as well
and all the rest of us
all those of us who are not governors or
senators but all the rest of us here who
care about the direction of the country
we should take note too i'm michael
knowles that's the michael knowles show
see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadofsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
john bickley here daily wire editor in
chief wake up every morning with our new
show morning wire on today's episode a
federal court strikes a major blow to
biden's vaccine mandate the latest
developments on the covet front and
britney spears is freed from
conservatorship
join us and get the facts first on the
news you need to know with our show
morning wire